Welcome, Master!
Hello everybody.
Where are we?
Oh my gosh.
Where is this place?
We are getting turned around.
Welcome everybody aboard the USS Hornet!
And hello to you.
Hey!
Who let the ghost in?
Is that a ghost?
Oh my gosh!
How are you doing Ms. Smith?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm doing well today.
Welcome aboard the USS Hornet Sea, Air and Space Museum in beautiful sunny Alameda, California.
Welcome aboard everybody watching.
Glad to have you aboard today.
Yay!
Welcome aboard everybody.
Alright, so, where do you want to start?
Wait, do you want to do a little introduction first?
Tell everybody who you are, what you're doing, everything you got going on.
Hi, my name is Jeff.
I work on ship.
I do ship things.
Oh wait, sorry, let me rephrase.
Hi, I'm Jeffrey here at Battleship New Jersey Museum.
Oh wait, sorry, wrong curator.
Hi everyone, my name is Gabriel Cherry.
I am the marketing manager here at the USS Hornet Sea, Air and Space Museum.
And I will be your tour guide today as we show Ms. Mint the museum, USS Hornet CV-12.
Specifically CV-12, because here's a little nugget for you to start the tour.
This is the second USS Hornet aircraft carrier, meaning there was an aircraft carrier that preceded it.
Who here in chat knows about the Doolittle raid?
Well, the USS Hornet CV-8, which was the aircraft carrier that preceded USS Hornet CV-12, is the aircraft carrier that is famous for launching the Doolittle raid several months after the attack on Pearl Harbor back in World War II.
This ship is a memorial to that ship that sunk in the Battle of Santa Cruz.
So she not only carries the legacy of CV-8, but also, and we'll show this as well.
There are more ships that were called USS Hornets.
Specifically, there were 8 ships called Hornets.
Dating back to the American Revolution all the way back in 1775.
Hornets 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, and 10.
Well, realistically, these are just different versions of CV-12, but there were 8 USS Hornets throughout that history.
Oh my god, that's crazy!
So, this is technically the 9th version that holds the name.
But, currently right now, USS Hornet is the only ship the Navy has named Hornet, so she still holds the name today.
I like the little hornet down there.
Are we tall enough, you think?
I don't know.
Are we tall enough?
This is Buzz.
He's our mascot here at the museum.
Hi!
Buzz!
He's not really like Buzz Lightyear, but you know, he's buzzing around the place.
Nice cooler.
Okay, so, we're going to get the tour started here.
Yippee!
Now, first of all, the Hornet was laid down in 1942.
August of 1942, right?
See this aircraft here?
Mr. Cameraman, you can pan around.
Let's see just how big this space is.
Mannequin.
I like the lights over there.
Yeah, we're having a rave.
We have had raves here before.
Believe it or not.
Wait, actually?
Yeah, actually.
We actually have had private events here where we had a rave called Rattleship.
And it was this major 4,000 plus person event that we had here on the ship and it was this major rave that happened.
Oh, my God.
You heard it, everybody.
If you need a party.
Hey, party on the ship.
That's all I'm saying.
But, where we are right now is the hangar deck.
Now, most people think, oh, it's the hangar.
It's where the airplanes are stored.
No.
United States Navy doctrine dictates the aircraft need to be stored on the flight deck.
They're stored up there and tied down to little notches down in the ground.
So, I'll show you here.
You can't really see it because it's imprinted here on the ground.
So, Mr. Cameraman, you can take a closer look there.
There's usually little tie-downs here that hook into the ground.
You can also find these on the flight deck and they tie the aircraft down to prevent it from sliding off.
It would store them up there.
During World War II, Hornet had a flight complement of almost over 300 aircraft.
That's during World War II, back when we had smaller propeller-driven aircraft.
So, we'll stop with the aircraft here.
We'll talk about World War II.
Matter of fact, right here is Hornet's entire World War II history.
Oh my god!
That is all the planes, ships, and battles that the Hornet fought.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
So, each one of those...
Matter of fact, Hornet's actually responsible for sinking battleship Yamato.
So, Akankale fans, I'm sorry this ship sunk.
RIP, Akankale fans.
Oh no, Yamato.
Oh my god.
Propeller aircraft.
In World War II, the United States Navy was at a distinct disadvantage at the outbreak of the war.
The Japanese Zeros were lighter, more maneuverable, and had more powerful weapons at the time.
What you see right here is the training variant of the FN-2.
The FN-2 is one of the smaller propeller aircraft in the war.
This training variant was used to train pilots up in the Great Lakes.
So, landing on an aircraft carrier is one of the most difficult things you can do as a pilot.
It's on the water, it's moving up and down, left and right, and you have to be able to hit a specific mark on the aircraft carrier deck to be able to catch that hook.
We'll talk about tail hooks in a minute.
So, the fun part about this aircraft in our collection is that it was actually found at the bottom of Lake Michigan.
Oh!
What's it doing there?
Well, it was a training accident.
So, the pilot ejected and it jumped in the bottom of Lake Michigan.
This aircraft was soon found and brought to the USS Hornet and fully restored by our team here.
Wow!
That's another interesting fact.
All the aircraft you see here are restored by the USS Hornet volunteers.
Nobody's paid.
There are no government contracts.
We get no support from the government.
We get grants like any other museum.
But it's all volunteers that come here and give their time.
Oh my God!
Wait, what have you done then?
Man, I don't want to do this no more.
Sorry!
You're giving a wonderful tour for us.
Thank you.
Why are you bullying me?
I give a crap about the ship.
I like that Mike Chad is calling you Gabe Jeff.
Hi, my name is Gabe Jeff.
Gabe Jeff.
Gabe Jeff at your service.
But this represented the early part of the war.
The latter half of the war, post-US battle of Midway, the United States Navy learned a thing or two about how to design their aircraft to counter the Japanese.
Now, this is Miss June.
Everybody say hi, Miss June.
Hi, Miss June.
You look lovely today.
Miss June's a hag, so we have to be kinder.
She's a hag YouTuber.
Don't worry.
We're going to upgrade her.
We're going to get LTV.
We're going to do the whole thing.
Hags are in demand, right?
That's what I'm saying.
Miss June, I'm told we could do...
She doesn't know me.
But Miss June is a TVM adventure torpedo bomber.
Now, during World War II, and it would come around the latter half of World War I, in the interim war period, torpedo bombers were considered the pinnacle of naval warfare technology.
Why?
Because you could take a warhead, which is a torpedo, and you could fly it as close as you could to a ship and slam it into the side, knocking it, making a giant hole in the ship, making it take on water and sinking it.
Oh, my God.
What the torpedo you see right here is representative of the Mark...
I believe it's the Mark... Yes, the Mark 19 torpedo.
It's about 1,600 pounds.
1,600 pounds!
Yes.
I could take it.
Now, this is a prop.
Yeah, you could totally lift it.
It's fine.
Go, bro.
Mental goes to the gym.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Gym art.
Mental games.
Training art.
We got this.
Back to mental games.
Well, this torpedo would be carried...
The payload would be carried by Miss June, along with a crew of three.
And you notice how large this aircraft is.
Now, for reference, for everybody at home, I am 6'5".
Oh!
Notice how big this girl is.
She is a biggin'.
She is a biggin', alright.
But she has a big payload.
Now, the TDM torpedo bomber was regarded as one of the best torpedo bombers because of its armament.
But also, it was resilient.
It could take hits.
It would not go down without a fight.
And it could take a lot of bullet holes and get back their crew safely.
So, American pilots had a higher retention, lower casualty rate with this aircraft than they would with counterparts on the Japanese side.
See?
You gotta get them thick.
Exactly.
You gotta get them dummy thick.
Miss June, you're dummy thick.
I'm sayin'.
Yeah.
So, you notice how this aircraft has folded wings.
You notice how this aircraft has folded wings.
It's a wildcat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Miss Mint, why do you think that is?
Storage?
Oh.
Plus five points for Miss Mint.
Yippee!
You wanna get as many aircraft on the carrier as possible.
And the only way you're gonna do that is if you find a way to fold the wings.
Because the wings take a majority of the space.
But if you fold them and you put them on the flight deck nice and tight, packed to each other.
They still do this in the Navy today.
All naval aircraft have foldable wings.
They fold them up and they store them and take them where they need to go around the world.
Because the whole point of the Navy is to have presence around the world 24-7.
To be able to extend our reach.
So, every aircraft has this.
It's controlled by hydraulic systems that move these wings into position up and down.
But, here's the thing though.
Aircraft are never to be fueled, nor do they have their weapons put on them on the hangar deck.
That is too dangerous.
You're essentially creating a tinderbox.
Because if you have everybody running around.
And let's say we're at war.
It's World War II.
Someone drops a bomb in here.
And there's fuel and there's bombs and there's ammunition.
Everywhere.
It's like the biggest explosion ever.
It did happen in World War II during the Battle of Midway.
A lot of the aircraft carriers of the Japanese, most notably the Akagi.
Actually had an implosion upon one bomb drop that penetrated the deck.
Exploded the entire interior of the hangar deck.
Because of how much fuel, weapons, and men were moving during the time.
It caused a whole new reaction that destroyed the carrier.
Oh my god!
They learned fast from that then.
We learned fast from that too.
So here's what happens.
This area is armored from that.
There are major hangar bay wars.
You guys can see down a ways over there.
Part of the hangar bay is already closed.
We're able to seal off parts of the hangar deck in case there's a fire.
So that way we can go ahead and keep operating.
But also damage control crews can focus on one area.
What?
Oh wow, that's so intuitive.
Oh my god.
The Essex class was designed with the lessons learned from the past.
So they wanted to be able to take what they...
The name is all about evolution, all about learning, all about doing it better the next time.
So they took what they learned from the Japanese, applied it to the carriers going forward.
But as we move on, World War II ended.
So, what happened with aircraft?
Well, they got bigger.
They got heavier.
They went faster.
They had bigger engines, more propulsion.
And because they got bigger, we could only carry little aircraft.
We couldn't carry less aircraft.
Here's an example of one aircraft.
The F-22.
Now, the F-22 is an amazing aircraft.
I love this aircraft.
Want to know why?
Why?
Because it don't need no missiles to be great.
We don't need a shotgun.
We don't need a lock-on with missiles.
The F-22 is known as the last gunfighter.
Because you know why?
It only had guns.
It had its machine guns.
It did not have missiles.
It had unguided bombs.
But it was an interceptor dogfighter.
People who pilot aircraft were trained for air-to-air combat.
I'm not good at dogfighting.
I got it.
We'll teach you.
Okay.
We'll get you right.
You notice these doors right here?
This is where the cannons will shoot out.
Down in the interior right here, just so you can see what the jet intake looks like.
Yeah.
It is dangerous, but I'm going to stick my head in there anyways.
Echo!
Good morning, Vento!
The engine will be inside of here.
And it will be sucking air through here to be able to create propulsion on the other side.
I have a question.
How often do birds get in there and stuff?
What if a bird gets in there?
Well, if a bird gets in there, you better enjoy the ejector seat.
Like you're going to Disneyland for free.
Oh, jeez.
Well, not necessarily free.
It costs maybe a couple billion dollars, but still.
Yes.
And I'll show you this right here before we leave this part of the ship.
What do I think that is?
What do you think it is, Ms. Schmidt?
A missile?
It's alright.
What type of missile?
Torpedo?
I don't know.
I'll give you a hint.
It makes a very, very big boom.
Like a nuke?
Back in the Cold War, it's theorized that the USS Hornet may or may not have had nuclear weapons aboard.
Uh-oh.
Metal gear.
This is an example of a nuclear warhead that the Hornet may or may not have had.
Wow.
I feel like it's smaller than what I would think of.
Big things come in small packages.
That's true.
That's me.
That is you.
There you go.
See?
You're a nuclear warhead super.
You're a big, big explosion.
We love it.
We love to see it.
I'm the big explosion.
During the Cold War, we would not say that we had the nukes aboard.
But this is an example of a warhead that would be kept.
We do not know exactly which ships had warheads because the Navy will not disclose that.
We can neither confirm nor deny.
Where would they... if those hypothetically would be stored on a ship, where would those be kept?
If I told you, I'd have to go home and tell my mom I'm sorry I spoiled it.
Hi, Mom.
Sorry.
Dang.
My sneaking mission is getting thwarted.
Are there any questions before we continue?
Yeah.
Chat, if you guys have any questions, feel free.
I will try and catch some.
Let's see what they have.
Feel free to interrupt anytime if you have questions.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you single?
What?
Listen, I am in a beautiful relationship with my body pillow.
It has the aircraft carrier with anime eyes on it.
I am happy.
You heard it here, you guys.
I'm sorry.
You don't stand a chance against that.
Actually, someone was asking about Azure Lane.
If you want to explain what you've done with Azure Lane before.
We have actually done multiple collaborations with Azure Lane.
They have actually helped support our anime and gaming convention called Carrier Con.
They have had a boost here, but also we've done merch.
We actually currently have a merch collab going on with them.
If you come to the ship, you can actually buy some of that merch.
You can also find it on our website.
But we also have done other collaborations, such as two years ago now, we hosted the Azure Lane 5th anniversary event here at the ship where we had cosplayers.
We had a whole show and we celebrated Azure Lane's five years.
That's so awesome.
We love doing events like that here at the ship because you know why?
It's about getting you, the audience, whatever you're into, showing you, hey Hornet, we're open to it.
We love you guys.
I want you guys to connect with the ship in your own unique way.
I have two more questions from people.
Someone asked, how many aircraft can this carrier carry?
So that would depend on the era.
Is there a specific era?
If we're talking about World War II, that would be over 400 aircraft.
Talking during the Cold War, that would be about 100, depending on what type of aircraft we're talking about.
Because like I said, World War II aircraft were smaller.
Not you, Miss June.
Not you.
Smaller.
They were more compact.
We could even hang them from the rafters.
Cameraman, if you could show above.
We could hang them from above.
But when aircraft like the F-4 came along and notice how big she is.
That's saying you're not big.
We love you.
But when aircraft like the F-8 came along, that's when we had to adjust and the Hornet, unfortunately, became an outdated carrier.
That's why the class that came after it, USS Midway, if anybody's been to San Diego, California, USS Midway is down there as a museum, is a much bigger aircraft carrier and can support larger aircraft.
And that's why she stayed in service from almost 1945 all the way to the 90s.
Because she was able to be upgraded to be able to carry and support larger aircraft.
The Hornet, unfortunately, was decommissioned in 1972.
But everything you see here, folks, and this is fun fact, is as you see it from when it was decommissioned in 1972.
The Hornet is a National Historical Landmark and has not been changed or altered in any way.
Obviously, it was gone to become a museum, but it's still authentic to what it was during the period.
Any other questions?
Next question?
Yeah, I have more.
Someone asked, I think they noticed your shirt.
They wanted to know if you served on any Navy ships and your background with the Navy.
Unfortunately not.
I actually gained my graduate degree.
And once I get my graduate degree, I am considering applying for OCS for the Navy in the Reserves.
But I have a Dutch family that has been in the Navy in the Marine Corps.
So I guess you could say it's in my blood.
I very much like to help preserve my family's history.
And I feel some way with what I do with the Hornet, I help to play a role in preserving their stories.
Respected.
Respect.
I have one more question, and then we'll keep going.
Someone asked, was there ever a situation on the flight deck similar to the fire on the USS Forrestal?
So, no, there was not.
The Hornet actually had a great track record for its damage control and its safety over here.
Unfortunately, what happened with the Forrestal was a freak accident.
But the Hornet did not have any incidents of that happening.
Did we have some botched landings?
Of course we did.
Every carrier had that.
But we did not have a major fire.
Okay.
During 1944-45, there was a major typhoon that happened during the war.
Hornet noticeably had the front of its flight deck dented.
And you can find, if you Google it right now, Hornet flight deck dented, you will see an image of the USS Hornet's flight deck over the side of itself.
Because the typhoon crashed on the bow of the ship and crashed on the flight deck.
What?
I'm looking it up.
Dented.
Matter of fact, you're probably wondering, hey, why is the flight deck bending?
Well, let's take a guess, Ms. Mitt.
What do you think the flight deck is made of?
Made of?
What's it made of?
Metal.
Wrong.
Wrong?
What's it made of?
Wood.
Wood?
Made out of teak.
What?
During the war, the Navy wanted to produce ships fast.
And the idea was, they're not going to be in harm's way.
They're not going to be like battleships and taking shells.
So we don't need to armor our flight decks.
So we weren't like the British that thought, oh, we're taking so many hits, we need to make our decks out of steel.
The X-class carriers have teak decks.
It was only the midway class that got upgraded to have armored flight decks.
Whoa.
Most people don't know that.
Yeah, I just saw, I see the deck is bent like 90 degrees.
It's crazy.
There you see, that's what happened when the typhoon happened.
Wow.
This is one of my favorite aircraft right here.
The A-4 Skyhawk.
Now, this is a training variant of the A-4 Skyhawk, but it'll get the point across too.
You're probably wondering what this long tip pole is.
Yeah.
This is used for underwater, in-air refueling.
So if you search up in-air refueling, anybody at home, you'll usually large tanker aircraft, and this is normally what the Air Force does.
There's a large tanker aircraft that circle around in different areas of warfare.
If aircraft need to do refueling, and they need to get back to their carriers, or they're on extended missions, and they may be running low, they're able to take this nozzle and connect it to a giant cone that helps to move it into position, and they can refuel while they're in the air.
This variant had this because they were training pilots to be able to do that.
So when they would go out to war, or they would go on sea, they would know how to do it properly.
But the A-1 Skyhawk, funny enough, it was actually used in Top Gun.
Not the movie, the program.
Top Gun is a program for the Navy's best pilot pilots.
If you've seen the movie, you understand, but there are some inaccuracies with that.
I love Top Gun!
We all love... hey, hey.
The need for speed.
What's Tom Cruise do?
He's like...
Goose!
Why is it such an accurate impression?
He's like, I gotta tell you, I love flying.
But the A-4 Skyhawk.
This aircraft was fast, light, and nimble.
Now, we actually have a docent here at the USS Hornet, Mr. Alan Cartwright, who flew over 400 combat missions in Vietnam in this aircraft.
Not this one specifically, but the A-4.
Mr. Cartwright is a great man.
If we see him around, I'll definitely introduce you.
But, the A-4 Skyhawk was fast and nimble, and it could imitate MiGs.
So, during the 60s, 70s, and 80s, they would use the A-4 as the adversary aircraft.
The adversary aircraft being when the pilots go out, so if you've seen Top Gun and they're in the F-14s and they go out, of course you're seeing the F-5s out there.
But, they would use this aircraft to be the aircraft that would dogfight against the pilots to test them.
Because they were faster, they were more maneuverable.
It was more of a challenge.
They needed to make their pilots more resilient in the face of adversity.
So, they put them at a disadvantage.
I know, I mean, that's how you get better, right?
Iron sharpens iron.
Here's the cool part about this aircraft.
So, it has a way of slowing itself down naturally.
No hydraulics, machinery, air pressure.
So, when it takes off on the carrier, and we'll go over how that works, too.
When it takes off on the carrier, it's pulled by the catapult and, shoom, launched.
When it's in the air and it has to build airspeed, on the wing and the stabilizer, as it goes faster and faster, it starts moving.
Whoa!
Until it comes to the lock position.
Now, Mr. Cameron, take a look here.
Look how much of a blade it is here.
Nice and nimble cut through the side.
Yeah!
You have very little drag.
You have air pocket around the aircraft as it flows through the air.
This helps it create more speed.
When it slows down, you start seeing this fall down.
Guess what this does?
Creates more drag.
It's a safer aircraft and helps land it smoother.
How heavy is that to push?
Well...
Oh, OK.
Onegai Muscle.
Anyways...
The A-4 was a great aircraft.
It was a workhorse of Vietnam.
Well, here, I'll show you how it did over here.
So, aircraft on aircraft carriers all have one distinct feature.
They have a holdback bar and they have a resting gear.
This is called a tail hook.
You notice right here, this little groove right here.
You notice this little groove right here.
See how it curves in?
This is meant to catch a thick cable that is laying on the flight deck that is pulled by hydraulics on each side of the flight deck.
They adjust the tension for the weight of the aircraft, the speed of the aircraft, and what type of aircraft it is.
They adjust it so it catches right here and it helps to yank the aircraft back.
Here is a little question.
Do you think when an aircraft lands on an aircraft carrier, does it go full power or does it cut its power?
Cut its... Is this a trick question?
Full power then, right?
I don't know, Ms. Min.
Is it a trick question?
Full power!
That's what my chat said.
Let's give her her roses.
She's right.
Full power because you know why?
The hydraulic cable needs to adjust for the speed of the aircraft.
It needs to adjust it and pull it back.
And so when it goes full power, it can adjust properly.
Over here, you have this handy dandy tool.
Oh, it's locked.
This is a steel bar.
It weighs no more than about an ounce or two ounces depending on the size and weight of the aircraft.
Would you believe that when the aircraft is on the flight deck and it's getting ready to launch, it's going full power, right?
And there's a cable that holds it to an anchor point on the ground.
Would you believe this holds back this aircraft?
That thing, just that?
Yup.
Here's the cool part.
Right here, you see this little groove right here?
So each aircraft during the era, during the Cold War, had a holdback bar like this specifically designed for that aircraft.
This holdback bar, depending on the tension, depending on the aircraft and what they would adjust on the catapults down the catapult room, which we'll go see soon, they would adjust it and once, if they hit the launch button, the green shirts, once they hit the launch button,
ping.
It would separate, but it takes a specific amount of pressure and torque to be able to pull it apart.
Designed for this specific aircraft.
There are several like it, but none are, no single one works on multiple aircraft.
All custom made.
Now, in the Navy nowadays, they have a reusable one.
These were disposable.
Once they broke apart in single bars, they throw them over the side, but nowadays they have reusable ones that are recyclable.
They can retract and they are more modular for other aircraft.
Oh, I think I remember last time you showing the ones that were like, you talked about that too, when we were out on the flight deck and how they...
Yeah, I remember that.
Yes, ma'am.
And that's just a closer look about how it works though, on an actual aircraft.
Yeah, yeah.
Here's a crazy thing.
It's a gift shop!
Gift shop!
I know, I know.
Let's take a look at this baby.
This is the S2 Tracker.
Who can guess what this aircraft was used for?
Who can guess, everybody?
Who can guess?
I'm looking at chat.
You get a cookie if you guess.
Someone said cargo?
Rescue?
It's not a chocolate chip cookie.
It's an oatmeal raisin, so it's kind of...
It's a cargo?
Someone said cargo, recon, rescue.
We got lots of people.
Bombs?
What else we got?
Assistance?
Well, chat, I hate to tell you, but none of you are right.
What is it?
This is used for anti-submarine warfare.
In the latter half of Hornet's history, she was designated a CVS.
Now, CV is a designation used to denote an aircraft carrier in all specifications.
So, there's CV 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
CV 12 is the 12th aircraft carrier.
So, CV aircraft carrier dash 12.
Aircraft carrier 12.
USS Hornet.
But, when they turned it into CVS, that meant the designation was anti-submarine warfare aircraft carrier.
So, the Hornet was complemented with multiple helicopters and aircraft that were meant to fight submarines.
To do recon.
To be able to find said submarines.
Yeah.
This aircraft...
This is probably one of the most interesting parts about it.
This aircraft could actually hold a torpedo and launch a submarine.
But, also, it could hold def charges, too.
You know what a def charge is, chat?
I don't know what a def charge is.
A def charge is a little device that's a bomb.
But, here's the thing.
Depending on when they use sonar, and they use sonar buoys, they can drop sonar buoys to be able to find submarines out in the ocean.
Depending on the def, the size, and where they need to drop the def charge, they can adjust it to feel pressure underwater.
If it reaches a certain pressure, then it, boom, blows up.
But, here's the thing.
It doesn't need to hit the actual submarine directly.
Anybody here drink soda?
Who drinks a soda can, right?
Like, Dr. Pepper, Sprite, you know, hey, so you want a Sprite cranberry?
It's the holidays, so you want a Sprite cranberry?
Oh, no, LeBron James is coming.
Anyways, you take a can, and you put it underwater.
What happens if you go in a pool with it?
And you go deeper, deeper, deeper, deeper.
Exactly.
It starts imploding.
It starts tightening up.
So, therefore, this aircraft drops the def charge, submarines underwater, drops the def charge, reaches a certain def, boom.
It causes a little dink to the submarine.
And you know what happens?
Submarines are pressurized.
So, here's what happens.
A little dink.
Teeny, tiny, little submarine.
Hand-holding.
Exactly.
Unwarranted hand-holding.
I don't like that.
But the S2 Tracker was used for these things.
They had anti-submarine torpedoes.
They had those def charges.
It was dedicated during Vietnam to finding Russian submarines.
Did we find Russian submarines?
I couldn't tell you.
I don't know the answer to that.
But we were prepared in case of anything.
In case.
Any questions, chat?
Any questions?
Question, question.
Questions all?
I think we're good.
You guys stop asking weird stuff.
What are they asking?
They're asking if you work out.
Oh, you're keychain too.
I do a little cardio.
I do Zumba.
Wait, what about your keychain?
I think my mom's watching.
Hey mom, are we doing Zumba class on Tuesday?
Hey, if you can't do Zumba with your mama, you don't love your mama.
You gotta do Zumba.
Exactly.
You gotta get right.
FJ-2 Fury.
So we talked about the advancement of aircraft and we showed some of the more advanced aircraft.
But this was actually one of the first aircraft to be post-propeller jet-propelled aircraft to grace the Navy.
FJ-2 Fury shares a similarity with a certain MiG, if you're familiar.
But this was one of the first aircraft to be vastly deployed in the fleet.
On the back over here, it says Marines.
Here's a little fun fact.
If any of you are Navy veterans, you'll probably get a kick out of this.
If the Navy doesn't want the aircraft, they give it to the Marine Corps.
It's an inside joke.
Sorry, I was copying and pasting a question so I can ask it later.
I can ask it now, it's okay.
We're doing copypastas and we're on a tour.
It's questions for you!
Hey, did you know that in terms of human anatomy...
Shut up!
Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
The fitness gram test is an aerobic exercise.
Oh my god.
Anyway, if there's any more questions on the aircraft on this deck, we're going to head down below.
Any questions?
We'll head over there.
Oh no,
the little decontamination thing is behind the curtain, isn't it?
Oh, yeah it is, unfortunately.
Sorry guys.
But, we do have more exhibits down below.
Is that okay?
Yeah!
Before we continue though, Miss Mint, would you like to say who this is?
Who what is?
Oh, the bell!
What is the bell's name?
Oh, you told me.
It's Beffrey.
It's like Jeffrey Jellyfish.
Hi Beffrey!
I was like, Befferson?
I was close.
Alright, we're going to head down below deck.
Below deck time!
Is Beffrey official?
Is that it's actual official name?
No, I just made it up.
Oh.
Hey, you gotta have some fun.
You could have lied.
You could have lied just now and said, yeah, that's it.
And then, when I visit...
Hey, listen, listen.
I'm not going to do that.
You know why?
Why?
Because it's all going to get aboard the USS Hornet.
Actually, before we go below deck, I'm going to show you one of the haunted areas.
Haunted!
You guys!
My people.
Oh,
rocky.
Oh, spooky.
Oh no, the lights will flicker on and off.
Oh god.
I bet five ghosts have touched that fire extinguisher.
I get it.
Too spooky.
You're too scared.
I get it.
You're chicken.
Baby, baby.
To where?
Sorry, it cut out a little bit.
Where are we?
This is called the Fossil.
We may lose connection here.
But this is called the Fossil.
This is the anchor room.
See these giant chains over here?
Yeah.
Not picking that up.
Way too heavy.
I can do it.
Of course you could.
You know what?
Mint, give me your strength.
Yeah!
All upon the mints, and the ghosts, and the VTuber fans.
Give me your power!
But, funny enough, this room was not only just the anchor room where the sailors would retract and detract the anchor.
It was actually where the Marine Corps would work out.
So you're looking at the Marine Corps' gym.
They lifted these instead?
Hey, Marines, they're tough as nails.
So I wouldn't doubt.
Any questions about this room before we go?
No, I think we're good.
Or is there anybody in chat?
If there are, I'll just ask them.
Funny enough, this is a beautiful room.
Someone said, where are all the crayons?
We keep them below deck because we don't want them to find them and eat them.
This, right here, is the junior officer's berthing.
If you were a commissioned officer, and you have a four-year degree, you go into OCS or went to Naval Academy, you get some of the best digs on campus here.
You've got drawers, you've got all these amenities, you've got more privacy, you have a private head and all that jazz.
But this is one of the most premium berthing areas on the ship.
Below deck, enlisted to sleep on racks.
Here, they've got mattresses, they've got all the nice digs.
And funny enough is, we actually still use this to this day.
Our overnight program, we have our live-aboard program, where people can come, take a tour of the ship, do a ghost tour, even.
They can stay on the ship, sleep overnight, and get fed.
You get to have a wholesaler experience.
What?
That's crazy!
The really world-class, great program.
Our head of education, Heidi, she runs a great overnight program.
Ghost tour.
I do have a ghost story, though.
Yeah?
Right, so, bear with me here, okay?
Okay.
So, one night...
One night, I was here at the ship, and I heard a...
...clawing...
...at the...
...on the pipes.
And then I heard the words, it's the lash-slinging, ash-stinging, ash-stinging slasher.
And then I lost my act.
Oh, too spooky for me!
It's the lash-slinging, ash-stinging, bash-stringing slasher.
The hash-slinging, crash-bringing...
Dash-stringing...
Yeah, three spooky, five me.
So true.
You're scaring my chat!
Let's calm down.
And then the worst part was when we had a ghost tour, and we said, hey, let's have a pizza party, and a certain bear showed up.
Wow, you're getting all the heavy hitters.
It's not my fault that, for some reason, Freddy Fazbear showed up on the ship.
I bet you get good reverb when you do that.
How do you mean, Freddy?
He's like...
Oh, here's one of the many ship stores!
So, goods and services were very, very rare at sea, so you had your ship's officer stores here.
Designated officers could buy cigarettes, they could buy candy, they could buy coke, they could buy anything from several stores here on the ship.
As we go below deck, you'll see where we had the ice cream machine.
You'll also notice a lot of these red canisters around here.
These are for damage control, fire retardant.
So, we keep this below deck, so in case one area of the ship is on fire, or under attack, or we need damage control, we're able to move supplies quickly.
This is the part that's on fire.
If this part's on fire, we're sure in trouble, aren't we?
Alright, who's hungry?
I'm hungry!
Me!
Welcome to the officers' wardrobe.
Now, this area has been beautifully restored by our volunteers here, but if we were at sea, or if we were in port, this would be a five-star restaurant that the officers get to go to, including the captain.
You see white tablecloths, you see fine china, like we have over here.
You'll notice the fine china, that was huge.
Matter of fact, to this day on the ship, we host our own officers' tea ceremony, so one of the things you can do aboard the Hornet is experience a Navy officers' tea ceremony.
Yep, hosted by our CEO.
So, this room was where hopes and dreams went to die.
On account of that, ice cream in the Navy during World War II was a rare occurrence.
Now, in at port, all the officers bring their spouses, the captain comes aboard, and his wife comes aboard.
Officers in the Navy were trained that when a woman comes aboard, walks through this door here, all are to stand up at attention.
Especially the captain's wife, when she comes, she presents herself, and all the officers are at attention, and when she sits down, everybody sits down.
Respect for the captain's wife.
So, here's what happened.
The captain's wife got to decide one crucial thing, and this is where the hopes and dreams thing comes into play.
So, the Hornet had ice cream, right?
So, aboard the ship, the captain's wife would decide the menu for the night, and the waiter on her would say, would you care for dessert, would you care for ice cream tonight?
If she said yes, everybody got to have ice cream, yay!
If she said no...
Nobody's having ice cream that night.
What?!
That's so messed up!
It's tradition, Ms. Smith.
We respect tradition here.
What if she's like, I'm lactose intolerant, oh no.
And guess what, then the whole ship's lactose intolerant.
We ain't having no cows here.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry, that's the worst tradition.
Yeah, not a lot of people in the Navy were keen on it.
Here's a great picture from our collection.
This is Hornet during the 40s, during World War II.
Notice how the front of the deck is open, you have anti-aircraft guns.
You have sailors, when they come into port, they're usually lining the deck, you see in the Navy all the time.
They man the deck, they line across the edge of it as they come into port, but you notice how this is open right here, right?
Fast forward about 30 years.
Closed up.
Storm bow.
Stopped water from coming into there.
This is where the fossil and the anchor is.
So that whole area we were where the anchor was, was open originally, but then it was closed up when Hornet got her 1950s retrofit.
Oh, why?
Did someone fall overboard?
No, ideally it was just expanding the technology at the time.
Hornet not only got her new bow, but aircraft carriers during World War II were straight deck.
Because propelled aircraft, they go forward, right?
And they can land, and they can land softer.
Jet aircraft need more room for air.
So, as we got catapults, but also we got an angled flight deck.
So you would have the straight deck, but then you would have a little mini side deck that would go over the side here.
Landing aircraft, landing on the side.
Aircraft taking off, take off forward aft.
Oh wait, no, forward.
So, that was during the retrofit.
Here's an example right here of when she was a straight deck carrier.
Remember how I told you the 96th Navy Doctrine is aircraft need to be stored on the flight deck?
They look like little Metal Gears!
Oh my god!
Exactly!
Wow, it looks like Metal Gear Red!
Here's the Hornet after the war.
Shortly after.
But if you want to see what the Hornet looks like now, from bird's eye view.
Remember how I mentioned the angled deck?
So, still have the straight deck for aircraft taking off.
This is where aircraft land.
Wow!
So, they're all kind of compact in there.
How do they take off?
So, they would move the aircraft down to the hangar deck, but also they would move them behind over here when they're going into flight operations to be able to launch aircraft.
They would use the elevator.
So, you notice this is an elevator.
There's an elevator forward, there's an elevator over here.
We have three elevators on the Hornet.
That would bring aircraft up and down as we're getting ready to launch aircraft and prepare them for flight operations.
I have someone asking you a question.
They said, ask him what steak and lobster means.
Steak and lobster.
Isn't that what the Air Force enjoys?
Uh-oh.
Do we got some Air Force people here?
Man, you got all the great stuff, huh?
Hey, I'm not trying to cause a turf war here.
Hey, step off.
Here's the buffet table for the wardrobe.
That's what we know as the wardrobe.
Officers get some of the best steaks and some of the best food on the ship.
Oh, wow.
Wow, there's actually food in there.
Baked food.
Nah, it's real.
Okay.
Man, you're making me hungry.
Let's get lunch.
I like how everything is mint colored.
I could tell.
Thank you.
I feel like royalty.
Notice that Elander and Globe right there.
Right here.
This is the Marine Guard post.
Nobody gets to cross this line.
There will be a Marine Guard in here 24-7.
Nobody gets to enter this area unless otherwise authorized.
Right there, the general orders.
General orders to take charge of this post and all government property in view.
To walk my post in a military manner, keeping always on the alert and observing everything that takes place within sight or hearing.
To report all violations of orders I am instructed to enforce.
To repeat all calls from posts more distant from guardhouse than my own.
To quit my post only when properly relieved.
To receive, obey, and pass on any sentry who relieves me.
All orders from the commanding officer of the day, officers, non-commissioned officers of the Guard only.
To talk to no one except in the line of duty.
To give the alarm in case of fire or disorder.
To call the corporal of the Guard in any case not covered by instructions.
To salute all officers, colors, standards, not case.
To be especially watchful at night and during the time for challenging.
To challenge all persons who are near my post.
And to allow one person to pass without proper authority.
Yes, sir!
I'm not a Marine, but they would know how to do that probably.
Over here you have some of the M1 brands the Marine Corps would use.
But this Marine Station, nobody would pass by.
We would have the Marine on guard here in the cage at all times.
Wanna know why?
Because this is where we store the big boys.
What's dark?
Oh no!
What did you say?
Um...
I think those are...
Bombs?
Oh my god, the guy back there scared me.
This is a 6-inch battleship shell.
Now remember guys, I'm 6'5".
That's how big this is.
Oh my god, it's like a big baby.
Exactly.
You also have 2,000-pound bombs right here.
Drake, you also have training bombs.
These are practice bombs that the Navy would use to be able to train pilots out on their bombing runs.
But where we are is the armored compartment where the magazine is, all around us.
This railing system would hook bombs up to chains, move them up and down.
You have a bomb elevator there that will take them to the flight deck.
Also here is the hangar deck.
All of the weapons are stored down here when we take them to the flight deck because nothing is armed on the hangar deck.
It's low and simple on the flight deck.
When you load it up here, there's a giant wall right here.
Armor, of course.
Move it out of the way.
Move it up.
Load them up.
Rail system in there.
Wow.
Someone asked, are those 500-pound bombs World War II-era armor piercers?
No, they are not armor-piercing bombs.
They are firearms.
Oh,
here!
Here's a close-up of the practice bombs right here.
See some of the sand that's in here?
These are heavy.
They are meant to simulate actual weapons to give pilots a better idea of what the ordnance they're working with.
See right here?
You see some of the sand that they were packing in there?
Nice and tight?
Absolutely.
We love sand.
We eat sand.
Well, I don't know.
I don't really like sand.
It's rough.
It's gross.
It's everywhere.
Okay, okay, Anakin.
I don't like sand!
Here's another compartment.
Here's a good example of how a bomb looks when it's dropping.
It's a 1,000-pound bomb.
It has its guidance flaps there that help to circle it around to be able to make it reach its target as projected.
Some have laser guidance.
Here's actually a .50 cal.
Wow, cool!
Big shell.
Here's some of the shells that you would see.
40mm ammunition.
Oh my god.
That's long.
Any questions from the crew?
Any questions, anybody?
Any questions?
Oh, you said big shell.
Sorry, that was a Metal Gear reference.
Of course.
This is a Metal Gear stream.
Come on, man.
Listen, listen, nanomachines, son.
You gotta love them.
Let's see.
Hey, folks, I want to introduce you to my friend here.
This is Steve Lutell.
He's a U.S.S.R.C.
What did you do in the world's greatest branch of military?
I was a plane captain in the Marine Corps.
Wow!
How did you learn all of that?
Come on!
Well, plane captains are responsible for an airplane.
The plane belongs to them, not to a pilot.
That's a misconception people have.
They don't get to fly the plane, but the plane belongs to them.
So they have the plane ready for whoever will show up to fly the plane.
So don't get misdirected by names on airplanes.
That's just a plane that happens to have a pilot's name on it.
That's what I would do.
Help them, answer any of their questions, put them in the cockpit.
The last thing I'd say, have a nice flight.
Bring my machine back in one piece.
Sir.
If it says sir afterwards, I can get over it.
Of course.
I love Steve.
He's actually endorsing the training when I first came aboard ship as a volunteer back a couple years ago.
So Steve, thank you for helping me aboard.
Hey, go Bears.
Go Bears.
Nice to meet you, Steve.
Bye, Daniel.
Alright, where are we right now?
Well, we're going down into the bow.
Oh, no.
The chain.
Bring it closer to the camera.
Oh, no.
We're going deep into the bow of the ship.
Ooh.
Where we're going is the bread and butter of what makes a carrier an operator.
Little knobs.
Welcome to the catwalk room.
Where you are standing, where you're standing right now is the giant hydraulic piston to help launch the aircraft forward.
Alright, who wants a drink?
We've got whiskey.
We've got rum.
We've got gin.
We've got beer.
This is not a drinking stream.
We're not doing that here.
Hydraulic fluid.
We just make fun of it.
So, you have the hydraulic fluid, and you would mix it in, and you pump it into this baby.
This is the pork cat.
Cat!
Cute!
We like the pork cat.
But you notice the giant cables that get the rocks retracted.
This pulls the piston back.
When we're in flight operation, this room is really, really light.
I bet, yeah.
Here's a general idea of how the catwalk room works.
You have the hydraulic room here, and you notice how it's back over here.
Well, that's because all the tension is pulled back.
Pistons pull back.
As the aircraft is launched, we get a full view of it.
Pumping it full of hydraulic fluid to power the hydraulic cat.
Pulls it.
There's the cable that Pamela Smith, last time we talked about how the aircraft would pull down the flight deck.
You're seeing how that works underground.
It's connected, but through multiple decks.
Pulls the cable, helping to launch the aircraft.
And then when it's done, they retract it, building more tension on the catapult, resetting it for another launch.
And they can do that in about five minutes.
They can get several aircraft in the air in about five minutes.
That's insane.
But you can fire it down here.
So let's say we're up in the flight deck.
They give me a signal.
Matter of fact, there's a light right here.
First ready.
Fire the tension.
The light's not working.
Anyways.
But, first ready.
Put it on standby for green.
Green means we're ready.
Final ready means we can fire.
Here's the big red fire button.
Do I press it?
Press it!
Fire!
And we launch an aircraft.
Someone asked or said they heard that modern cats use steam.
Do you know anything about that?
Yes, modern cats use steam.
But the most modern cats aren't using steam.
They're using electromagnetics.
Modern carriers, Gerald R.
Ford class, are using electromagnetic catapults, which is the streamlined and newest way to be able to launch aircraft effectively and without putting as much strain on the catapults.
Steam creates strain and hydraulics even more.
They moved from hydraulics into steam and they've been using that for a couple of decades now.
But now they've moved on into the future.
Oh dang.
We're past steam.
We don't need that.
We don't need water.
Right.
Vapor.
Here we go.
So take a look here a little closer.
Here's the giant piston I told you about.
Wow!
This room is extremely loud when it fires forward.
How many people are losing their hearing?
Well, the Navy was not adamant about supplying earplugs.
So that's why your grandpa can't hear you guys.
Any questions about this room before we move on?
Any other questions?
I see someone said, did the ship have any battery?
No, it did not.
It's on a generator and power plant.
Wow.
Any other questions, comments, concerns?
Someone asked, did you ever try any MREs?
When I first came aboard and I was volunteering as a docent, they gave me an MRE and said, oh, it just tastes like chicken.
Well, it didn't taste like chicken.
It tasted like...
Anyways.
I think that's all we need to know.
That's all you need to know.
Alright, now it's going up.
Be careful.
Watch your step.
This meant I've hit my head a great many times, and because I've done so, I haven't forgotten it.
So, I think I've learned my lesson.
Trust me.
I'm 6'5", and Mr. Caribbean here is about the average height of a World War II sailor.
I'm usually in trouble.
That's why my hat right here, I got a lot of marks.
How tall are you again?
I don't think I know.
6'5", man.
Alright.
We got a little beaver in here.
Oh, they shut off the lights, but I want to see the ice cream shop.
Crackers.
Where's crackers?
That's another one of the stores that officers can go buy goodies at.
Oh.
Oh my god, watch your head.
Yeah,
this does look like a horror movie, right?
Hey, you're the ghost seat here.
I figured you'd be right at home.
Yeah, I am.
Someone asked if they have an NBC display.
NBC display.
I'm not bringing it down.
Could that person ask for a report site?
Does this look more industrial?
Well, I can't find the light switch.
Anyways, we just got to the ice cream shop.
What?
That was the ice cream!
Well, here, I have the flashlight.
We got to see the ice cream.
You know what?
Let's see if you have a sweet tooth.
I mean... nah.
Anyways, this is called the G-Dunk.
Get your orange juice, milk, coffee, cola, root beer, hot dog, hamburger, spam sandwich.
Yes, they would make sandwiches out of spam.
Hot dogs!
Ice cream and milkshake too.
Strawberry, chocolate, vanilla.
The G-Dunk.
The G-Dunk was a premium spot where you could go get some ice cream.
Oh, here's actually the lights.
Yay!
See, this is why we go check.
But you'll notice some of the prices here.
Orange juice, 10 cents.
Milk, 10 cents.
Coffee, 10 cents.
Coca-Cola, 10 cents.
Root beer, 10 cents.
Hot dog, 15 cents.
Hamburger, 25.
With cheese, Mr. Squidward.
With cheese.
Spam sandwich, 20 cents.
With cheese, Mr. Squidward.
With cheese.
In-bar, 10 cents.
Root beer, float, 20 cents.
Ice cream, 10 cents.
Milkshake, 20 cents.
Sheesh.
Can you imagine that now, back in the day, for only 10 cents, you could get all that.
For a dollar.
Imagine what you could get for a dollar.
Gosh.
I'd give it a buck fifty.
I feel like the Spam sandwich is... shouldn't that be the cheaper option?
It should be the cheaper option, but Spam was more rare back then, especially at sea.
Easier to get beef than it was Spam.
We're not done yet, so let's keep going.
Yippee!
We're over here, so if I go through this way, I should take that step.
We're heading to the next step now.
And if they're left there, be light.
Yes.
It feels like we're trespassing.
I know we're not, but because you're having to turn on the lights, all the lights are off.
So normally, I would take you down to see the interim to see the Horace PowerPoint.
But, we will lose Wi-Fi connection, so unfortunately, I can't take you down there.
But, for any of the viewers at home, if you are interested in seeing the interim, we do have daily docent tours that go on, and take you in-depth into the interim with a certified docent.
Dang.
Ok, well you guys just go and video it for me or something.
Alright, we'll go to the next step.
Usually when it's chow time, chow time.
Long line right here.
Every sailor is hungry.
Time for my kids to eat.
Over here is actually the menu shop.
So right next to where you eat, is where it's located.
Basically, this is at Sea Home Depot, right here.
It looks like it.
They would repair... we actually still use it today to repair the equipment we have here on the ship.
Oh, wow.
So it's like fully operatable still?
Yes, ma'am.
Thanks for our volunteers.
Thanks, volunteers.
Got your lunch tray.
Grab it right here.
Your lockers have to be nice and ready for the next round.
Wow.
But, over here you got your line, got your chow hall.
This is the enlisted mess deck.
This is where the officers go in.
Enlisted line up here.
They're with the premium stuff.
What kind of stuff would you get here?
You get eggs, toast, maybe bacon if you're lucky.
Lucky.
Lucky day.
Here, I'll tell you.
Just start on the galley light.
Let's take a look in here.
Look how big that kitchen is.
Oh, wow.
We have to cook for over 4,000 sailors.
Yeah, you have to be ready.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, that, that... Oh, my God.
The big, like, tins on the side.
That's crazy.
Back over here.
Yummy.
Here's the mess deck.
Mess deck.
This is where we go eat.
We got our buffet tables.
We still keep here for when we do overnights.
And we serve people aboard the ship.
But we use this area for overnight programs.
People are able to sit down.
But also, this is where the enlisted hall mess deck was.
Usually, you have a couple thousand sailors in at a time.
Yeah, looks like a little place to eat.
Yeah, it's not as nice as the officer one.
It looks very clean for being called a mess deck.
Oh, no.
I probably shouldn't go near an oven.
Okay, then you do not like to bake.
Well, we're going to take you near an oven anyways.
Because here's the bakery.
Yay, the bakery.
You will make all sorts of pastry.
They actually would make cakes in here for the officer for different ceremonies.
Right here, we actually have a nice little recipe.
So, anybody who wants a screenshot, try it for yourself.
You got Hornet Cake Donuts.
Well, that sounds awesome, actually.
Wait, I'm screenshotting it.
Wait, that sounds awesome.
I'm not in the way, right guys?
Okay, good.
There you go.
Make your cake donuts.
I know, I have a few people in chat that will tell me what they're making.
So, you guys better make this and let me know how it is.
Well, they would provide pastries for all the ships making bread.
One o'clock.
Got your master's ovens right here.
Making dough.
Store to board.
All done.
On ship.
Making bread, eh?
The bakery.
Hey, we gotta get our bread, you know?
We gotta get the bread.
Oh, yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
We gotta get the bread, you know?
Hustling.
Trying to get the bread.
The bread.
Make that bread.
Gotta make the cake.
Did that shut off?
No, that did not shut off.
There we go.
There you go.
Okay, let's go back.
Are there any questions I can answer?
Any questions?
Anybody?
Anything?
Oh, someone asked if he believes...
Do ships have souls?
Do you believe if ships have souls?
I believe every ship has a soul.
And I'm gonna get sappy here for a second.
Because you know why?
Because these ships represent the history of many young men and women who served so that we could be able to do what we do today.
And I believe that though they have passed on, their history and their souls and their stories still live on through the Hornet.
And that's the beautiful part about what we do here is that we help to preserve their story and tell you guys who don't know anything about that.
So, do I believe ships have souls?
100% I do.
There you go.
I respect it.
I mean I am a soul.
What's the Spongebob meme?
I have no soul.
I don't think I know that one.
It's the episode where Squidward tries to grab you Patty.
And Squidward is like, oh it's good for your soul.
And he's like, oh please.
Oh yeah!
That's right!
Someone asked in the bakery, how many crew would end up getting a birthday cake?
Not many.
Really?
When they made cakes, it was either the captain's birthday or if the Admiral was born, they'd make the cake to celebrate special occasions.
I feel like they should have at least done one a month, you know, for everybody who was in that month.
Oh, 4,000?
Yeah.
Man, that sure is a treat.
If I were captain, everybody would get cake.
Oh no!
Mutiny!
I'm overthrowing this ship!
Watch your step.
This is the office for Central.
And to this day, it's actually behind the scenes book at our admin area.
This is where a lot of our offices are, a lot of our head admins are, where they do their business.
But traditionally, this is where the Navy would be cabled.
Is your neck okay, Havenda?
I've done this for quite a while, trust me.
I'm taking it out.
I'm good.
Oh, they shut off the lights.
Okay.
Alright.
This is the horror tour.
Hey, you wanted the spooky, I brought you the spooky.
Thank you.
Oh, I look so spooky.
Oh my gosh.
You like Top Gun, right?
Wait, hold on.
I think... Oh, the Wi-Fi is catching up.
There we go.
Okay.
You like Top Gun, right?
Yeah, I love Top Gun.
This room look familiar?
Oh, it's loading.
Hold on.
Oh God.
I think... Yeah, I think the Wi-Fi is a little... It's denying me.
It looks like... Yeah, the briefing room.
It is the briefing room.
This is ready room four.
This is where pilots would be ready and get mission briefings before they would be headed out to their flight operations.
Like you saw in the movie in Top Gun, this is where they are with their chairs and their desks.
And they got their... It's basically like school.
Oh my God, the chairs look comfy.
They are comfy.
Those were donated many years ago to help restore the area.
Oh, wow.
Wait, so they weren't there before?
No, so something... And here's a fun fact.
Well, not really a fun fact, but here's a fact for the crew at home.
The Navy, when they give a museum ship, they do not give it as it really is because a lot of the equipment, whatever the guns or whatever the Navy can recycle for another ship, they take off the ship and or they destroy it.
And they clean out the ship.
So when we got the Hornet, she was cleaned out of all of her equipment.
So everything you see here today is almost over 25 years of building the museum back.
Wow.
Again, volunteers, folks.
Yeah, I guess that makes sense, though, to repurpose it or, you know.
True, but it is sad because we're not able to teach the next generation about what it was like.
All right, we'll keep moving on.
We'll do our best.
You're doing a great job.
Welcome to... any Marines in the chat?
Welcome to Marine Corps Central.
Oh.
Commanding officer's office here in the Marine Corps.
Every Navy vessel has a Marine detachment because Marine Corps is actually an attachment, is actually a department of the Navy.
Functions as its own branch of the military, but it does go in tandem with the Navy.
Navy gets you there.
So that's one of the offices you see here, Wakanda.
Oh.
This is one of the cleanest bathrooms you will ever see on the Hornet.
This...
I don't think the Wi-Fi likes the bathroom.
I don't think the Wi-Fi likes the bathroom, you guys.
All right.
We get denied the bathroom.
What?
It'll pick up, I think.
It'll pick up, you guys, don't worry.
Show us the poop deck.
We're in the spooky part.
The ghosts need the Wi-Fi.
A.K.A.
I mean...
I hope you guys are enjoying the tour so far.
It'll come back.
It'll come back, right?
Tell the ghost to stop downloading.
Eventually.
Hold on, let me see.
Oh no!
We lost him!
Maybe I should...
Oh no!
Yeah, we're back!
Sorry!
Yes.
Let's go up there.
There we go.
We're back here.
OK.
I'm sorry!
Guys, any questions?
Questions, questions?
Are we allowed to go outside or no?
Is it off because of the event?
We actually can go up to the flight deck.
I want to make sure we have Wi-Fi first.
Oh yeah, I know it's a little iffy out there.
Well, we can give it a shot.
Someone asked, what's your favorite part of the job?
Favorite part of the job is helping people who don't know about the Hornet discover the Hornet.
Because when I first started, when I became a volunteer, before I even became a volunteer, I didn't know the Hornet was still around.
I didn't know a piece of World War II history was still here.
And I would say what I get the most fulfillment out of is just connecting people with this place and helping them to know that it's more than just a military museum.
It's a sea, air, and space museum.
It's a pillar of the community.
And especially what we do for the community of the Bay Area, especially the educational programs we have for the youth.
It's really great to see how the Hornet, we are able to use our collections to be able to inspire the next generation of innovators, as well as STEM majors.
Yeah, it's really cool.
That's probably my favorite job, is teaching guys like me.
Oh, they asked earlier about your keychains on your...
Why doesn't everyone notice the keychains?
Okay, Mr. Cameraman, you don't have to do that.
All right, so these are VTubers that I have a connection with.
So this is Fumo Goro-Goro.
She is a friend of mine.
I met her a while back ago.
She's great.
She's a big fan of the USS Iowa.
Can't speak of praises enough.
And funny enough is these are VTubers that I actually work with because I actually run a VTuber group called V Fleet Project.
This is our USS Hornet, CV.
Cute!
This is our F-18 Super Hornet, because we have jet girls, not just ship girls.
This is Faye 18.
And she actually was in the concert with you, Miss May.
Yeah!
And this is her little sister, Ami 35.
She's an F-35 Lightning II.
I don't think she's a little sister.
Yes.
We broke him, you guys.
Sorry.
Professional.
Ok.
Let's go to the fight now.
Miss May, you are troubled.
What?
No.
Oopsie.
I'm not in trouble.
Are you guys ready for the best part of the tour?
Best part!
Alright.
This is the best part.
Probably the most historical.
The most thrilling.
Hey, you guys need to hold on to your seat, ok?
Hold on to your seat.
Oh!
I love this part!
Take a swig of your gamer socks.
Get ready.
We're about to go.
Ready?
Oh my god.
I love this part actually.
Ok, you guys ready?
Are you ready for this?
Here it is.
The Escalator!
Yeah!
Yippee!
Wow, it looks so crazy like this.
It's the Escalator you guys!
What a thrill.
Oh it's night!
Welcome to the flight deck.
I didn't realize it would be so dark.
But, we have one of the best views of San Francisco.
Check out the horizon.
That's San Francisco right over there.
Oh my god!
Wow, I didn't realize it would be so dark.
Thanks to kind donors and viewers like you, the Hornet can be seen from San Francisco because we now have our own.
Twelve!
Oh my gosh!
That's so cute!
Twelve.
Down this way is the F-14 Tomcat.
Yeah!
So we can try to go see it.
Hopefully we'll have a connection.
If we do, we'll go back.
But this whole area would be busy during the entire time.
Flight operations.
Nobody is supposed to be on the deck unless they are authorized and have a designated shirt.
Mr. Steve, Mr. Steve told you he was a plane captain.
He would wear a brown shirt on a flight deck.
He owns the plane.
He tells the pilot, hey, this is what you're doing.
That's crazy.
If you remember correctly, this is the catapult system, like riding a horse.
Yes!
So now you have actually seen the catapult down below.
So you see how it works here?
This is connected to the hydraulic pistons down below.
Wow.
Shows the aircraft down.
The big old piston.
This is another anti-submarine warfare aircraft.
Any questions?
Someone said, ask about the Apollo 11 and Apollo 12.
It was actually the aircraft carrier that picked up the astronauts, especially Apollo 11, with Neil Armstrong, Buzz Aldrin, and Mike Collins.
Picked them up back in 1969.
We're losing Wi-Fi.
Oh no!
Return to...
Oh God.
Return to the hangar.
Sorry guys for the technical difficulties.
Last time they took us on the deck and we were able to see quite a bit.
But I think the Wi-Fi is not so kind today.
Can you hear us?
Yes!
Hello?
Yeah.
Everybody, 07.
07.
There we go.
07 indeed.
F in the chat.
F in the chat, yeah.
Respect.
Anyway, we'll head down.
But yeah, here's just a brief thing of the flight deck.
If it was brighter we could see a little bit more.
Great view of the tower, right?
We call it the island.
It's not the tower or the bridge.
It's the island.
The island.
Wow.
What's the green light up there for?
Oh, that's just for... to make it look cool.
Oh, okay.
It's very seasonal.
Hey, we get festive around here, right?
Of course, Santa Claus is in an attack aircraft.
We'll be ready for him.
Are there any questions?
Questions, you guys.
Questions, any questions?
Questions, questions.
Oh, could be haunted, yeah.
The ghost party is happening up there.
Someone asked...
Someone asked, what's your favorite aircraft that operated from the Hornet?
Was it one of the ones you showed?
Yes, so my favorite aircraft is the F-8 Crusader.
Because, again, it did not use misguided...
It was a gunfighter.
And it was a one-on-one dogfight.
That's crazy.
Someone asked...
Wait, what is this?
Is it true that the slingshot operators wore red in case it snapped and hit them and unalived them?
So, no, that is not true.
So, catapult operators wore green.
Green is the general color, but they're the main operators for that.
Red works with ammunition.
They're responsible for munitions, loading up aircraft.
Vertical is responsible for fueling ground and plane captains, like Steve, like you saw.
And...
Red feels appropriate for ammunition.
There's actually a firefighting suit right here.
Trendy.
And so far, Apollo 11.
Apollo 11 flag right here.
Hornets emblem.
Oh my gosh, the cute little hornet!
And this is an officer's cutlass dress sword.
Now, there's actually an interesting video on our YouTube channel with our exhibits manager, who actually goes into depth about the history of the cutlass in the Navy, but also in other navies around the world.
So, you can actually find that on the USS Hornets YouTube channel.
Oh, cool!
I already heard that here, guys.
Study the blade.
The way the sword, like, right in my feets, that doesn't beat nanomachines.
Why?
Not that you know, you know.
Hey, I used to play college ball.
A tool of justice.
Listen, Senator Armstrong.
Listen, democracy, son.
That's what it's all about.
I think that's about everything I can show you right now.
So, any other questions?
Comments?
If you have any last questions, you guys, any last questions?
Someone asked, did this carrier operate the F7U cutlass?
The F7U?
Cutlass.
No, it did not.
We had A4s and A7s.
The A7 Corsair and obviously A4.
But we did not have the cutlass.
Someone said, any F4s still on display?
So, actually, yes.
We have an F4 Phantom that's in the back of the ship.
And unfortunately, I can't show it this time.
I'm sorry.
But, it's actually in restoration right now.
So, pretty soon, come by the ship, you'll be able to see it fully restored and fresh to paint.
Actually...
Remember that pilot for the Skyhawk I told you about?
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's crazy!
Wow!
Oh my god, he's styling.
So cool.
He's what we call a certified badass.
I can tell.
Any other questions to answer while we're waiting on Alvin?
There's a lot of questions.
Hold on, I'm scrolling up.
Oh, someone asked if the Hornet will be moving anytime soon or if it's going to be always here?
So, we hope that one day we can move.
We do not know right now, but it's through support from viewers like you and generous donors that hopefully someday we can move.
There you go.
Oh, someone said, did you guys film any movies, shows, documentaries at the museum that they should check out?
There are actually multiple documentaries that have been shot aboard the ship.
One of our movies called Eleven, which goes over torpedo group BS-11, goes over the history of a torpedo squadron that was here on the ship during World War II.
You can find that online.
It's called Eleven the Movie.
But there are multiple documentaries.
World of Warships actually did a really great in-depth job going over the Hornet's armament, going over its statistics, talking a little bit about its history.
You can go check that out on World of Warships website called Naval Legends.
Naval Legends?
World of Warships?
No way.
Well, it looks like Alan's busy.
No worries.
All right, folks.
But yes, you can find a lot of good stuff on different.
You can also look at our YouTube page.
We actually have some great miniaturized tours and little nuggets.
We also have a plane facts video that goes over some of the aircraft in more depth with an actual pilot.
Someone asked, do you like Ace Combat?
Have you ever played Ace Combat?
I have played Ace Combat.
I've played it many times.
I love Ace Combat.
Actually, funny enough, the devs of Ace Combat actually came to the Hornet to do some 3D imagery to be able... I don't know what's going to happen in the future, but they did come by a while back.
Shut up.
Wait, actually?
I don't know what's happening.
I just know they were from Ace Combat.
Shuai, shut up.
Wait, like recently?
Yup.
Oh my god.
I think you just made... that's so... where is Nan?
I don't know the answer to that, but it was really cool meeting some of them.
They came all the way from Japan.
And you know, they were really amazed by just seeing this place because they've never seen an aircraft carrier before.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think we need to end on that because I don't think we can talk about that information at all.
Well, we don't know.
We don't know.
No!
Right, right, right.
We know, but we don't know.
It's an unknown unknown.
So if you know the know, you know the know.
Double know.
Know what I mean?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for this.
This is so much fun.
I think everybody loved it so much too.
I've seen a couple people being like this is like one of my favorite streams you've done Mint.
So like, this has been just incredible.
Thank you.
Everyone's still calling you Jeff.
I see a couple Gabe Jeffs, don't worry.
Gabe Jeffs, okay.
Well, thank you very much for doing this tour.
We were happy to have you for Offices in Live and just taking the time to take out the ship, share with your community the ship.
I do encourage you if you're ever here, always welcome aboard the ship.
But also any of your viewers if you're ever here, please come support the ship.
The Hornet is a magical place.
You have some great veterans here who've served.
You have some great docents that knowledge, the wealth of just history that's here aboard the ship.
It's unfathomable.
And as a young person who's just gotten involved with the ship, I can safely say that anything you do counts, whether it's $2, whether it's a ticket to the museum, attending an event, or even just buying a piece of merch off our store.
It really helps to keep us afloat because we want to keep the Hornet around for many years to come.
Honey, you guys don't forget that Azure Lane stuff if you're like, oh, yeah.
We still buy our Azure Lane merch here at World of Ship.
Yeah.
Well, actually, where can people donate?
Someone's asking, where can we donate?
You can find it on our website.
So if you go to USSHornet.org, there's a big yellow tab in the top right corner.
You can click it and it'll take you to our donation page.
Straight there.
There you go.
If you are interested in donating to other museum ships, on Befleetproject.com, we actually have a donate tab that links multiple museum ships around the country and the world.
You have a direct link to go to their donate page.
This is USS Massachusetts, the Battleship Museum in New England.
This is Yorktown.
This is Iowa, Wisconsin.
You can find all that there.
So that's just a resource available.
Well, actually, before you go, I'm giving you another tour today.
Alan, can you introduce yourself to the folks at home and what you did in the Navy?
Yes, I am Alan Caranga and I flew the A-4 Skyhawk, which is this airplane right here, off the USS Ticonderoga during the Vietnam Conflict.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for your service, sir.
Yes, thank you for your service, sir.
It was nice meeting you.
I'm giving another tour.
I'm a wise guy, right?
Hey, you trained me, so I get the credit.
I was glad to see that Cal came back and beat Stanford.
Yeah, but we lost SMU the next week.
Okay, we got blown out.
See you Saturday.
What's happening Saturday?
I come here and I usually work on Saturdays here.
I usually try to tag along on tours or helping out at the front desk wherever we can to help with operating.
Even though I'm a marketing manager, I'm never above helping out.
Okay, guys, if you want to meet Jeff Gabe, you got to come on Saturdays.
Is that my name?
You know, some of my talent is watching right now, so if they actually see me, I'm going to get shit for sure.
That comes with the job.
Yeah, I know.
I get emails every day.
It's a badge of honor.
Like I told you, Ms. Mint, you got to love it.
You got to love the opportunities you give people.
And again, it's about magical places like this every day.
Thank you so much.
This was a lot of fun.
Hopefully we can do something again.
Anytime you want, Ms. Mint, I'm always available for you.
Thank you.
Thanks, folks.
You guys have a great evening.
Ms. Mint, always a pleasure.
Looking forward to the future.
And again, guys, thank you for your support.
Thank you.
Everybody say thank you, Jeff, Gabe.
Bye-bye.
Say bye-bye.
Yeah, I'm saluting.
You just can't see.
I see it.
I'm going to talk to my chat for a bit, so I will disconnect and I will talk to you all later.
No problem.
We'll see you soon, okay?
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
I had this background.
Sorry for the flashbang.
Yeah, I hope you guys liked the tour.
So sorry, so sorry.
That was so cool.
Yeah, he is very passionate.
You can tell about everything.
Great stream, Ms. Mint.
I'm not used to that.
I'm the maid, you know.
I'm not used to being called Ms. Mint.
I call the master and mistress, you know, Mr. and Mrs. Let me put on some music real quick.
Perfect.
Yeah, I hope you guys liked it.
It's, you know...
I'm glad that we had the opportunity.
Is his name really Jeff?
No, it's Gabe.
I think he was doing a bit.
He was doing a bit and Jeff just...
It kind of stuck.
But yeah, I did the off-season live on the carrier and then...
He messaged after and was like, if you ever want to do a tour...
A video tour, like a stream tour, we can set that up.
And so I'm really grateful because I think he said that the museum is closed today.
So he took the time to show us around, which I guess is better because we didn't have any...
It was a totally private tour for us.
So if you're ever in the area, of course, please go to the USS Hornet and you'll be able to see all the fun stuff.
And all the history and all the mechanics.
I'm sad because they have the...
It was behind the curtain where all the rave lights were, but they have the...
The little area where the astronauts went when they landed and they had to decontaminate them and everything.
I think that's so cool.
Stuff like that, you know?
So cool seeing the tour near me.
Went with my dad.
Oh, nice!
What was that Vtuber group he mentioned?
Vfleet.
Like V and then fleet.
So check them out!
The girls are so sweet.
I met some of them.
And some of them were in chat earlier.
Yeah, Vfleet.
Yes, yes, yes.
And I can't believe it's all volunteers.
I didn't know the stuff about the volunteers fixing everything up.
And...
And, like, everybody having to donate stuff.
That's crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
But yeah, I hope you guys had fun.
And a little history, but we got to nerd out a bit today.
It was fun, fun, fun.
I just heard quite a few Vfleet Vtubers also play Ace Combat.
Nan!
Nan, did you hear?
Nan, you're here.
Wait, did you hear?
That was such an awesome stream.
Thank you for... Oh, sorry.
Giving us the opportunity.
I owe a tour a win.
We can find someone who will tour us, you know?
I didn't care if he mentioned Carrier Con.
He did, he did.
One of the two times I went with the Hornet was when I spent like $400.
It was lit.
Took a picture with some cute Azur Lane cosplayers.
And I was really sweaty.
Yeah, they said that they did Carrier Con and then also some Azur Lane official events.
Which is just so awesome.
Sorry, I was busy playing Ace Combat.
You know what?
You'll just have to watch, Nan.
You missed the Ace Combat information.
Shame.
Someone leave a timestamp for him.
Anyway.
Pro made so many references.
I know!
How tall was he again?
Probably like, what?
6'2"?
Yeah.
Just gotta work for it, Mint.
Oh, okay, nevermind.
You're right.
6'5".
5'11".
Thanks for such a cool stream, Ms. Mint.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for joining me.
Pigeon, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you for all the superchats.
And the gifted memberships and everything.
I wanna go.
I wanna go and meet the other ghosts.
One day.
Two!
This tour was very interesting.
Hope we can do more tours in other places in the future.
Yeah!
I hope so too.
I would love it.
Especially when you get someone so passionate about it.
And just wanting to really explain everything.
I'm a big fan of US Navy so I enjoyed it so much.
Thank you!
Gonna meet Freddy Fazbear.
Yeah, yeah.
He didn't mention it, but there's so few aircraft carriers left.
Or rather, as museums in the US.
It's important to remember history and learn from it.
And also just so fascinating to see how technology was used back then and how it's advanced to where it is now.
It's so cool.
You gotta push Jeff into becoming a Vtuber.
That's not my job.
The Vfleet girl should.
He would be great on stream though, right?
Such a character.
Packing for the concert.
Concert soon.
Would you like to see a U-Boat tour?
Tour guide is a lot like streaming, honestly.
German sub.
I would love to see so many tours.
Thank you for the spooky donut!
I don't know what to expect at first, but this is awesome.
I'm so glad you thought so!
I remember when he gave... It was me and Lisa.
He gave us a short tour.
Before off-season.
Off-season live.
So I knew it was gonna be a lot of fun, right?
Dr. Big Sausage!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
It's our streak!
Yesterday was my birthday.
I'm old!
Can you sing me Happy Birthday MGS style?
Of course!
Of course, of course.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
It's our streak!
Happy birthday!
Nice.
Alrighty, guys.
I'm gonna head out.
It's really cool that y'all can set up tours like this.
So everyone can learn without having to be there.
Thanks, Mito.
Thank you guys for...
For hanging out with me.
And hanging out with us.
And going on tour with us.
Really appreciate it.
Glad you guys liked it.
So, have a good day!
Have a good night!
Otsu Mito!
I will see you guys when I see you next!
Have a good day!
Thank you for the stream!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye!